we begin this morning with the fallout
from president Trump's alleged
immigration comments the international
community and civil rights leaders
across the country are demanding an
apology from mr. Trump for the remarks
reportedly made at a bipartisan
immigration meeting earlier this week he
has denied using a vulgarity to describe
Haiti El Salvador and some African
nations the President and First Family
are in mar-a-lago in Florida for the
weekend as he continues to face a
backlash Errol Barnett is in West Palm
Beach with the president Errol good
morning good morning aside from the
global condemnation at president Trump's
remarks his choice of words has
threatened the highly sensitive
bipartisan talks over immigration and it
has further raised the risk of a
government shutdown when funding runs
out at the end of next week
under heated new accusations of racism
President Trump
signed a proclamation honoring dr.
Martin Luther King jr. on Friday no
matter what the color of our skin or the
place of our birth we are all created
equal by God ignoring questions from the
press about his own beliefs during a
bipartisan meeting on immigration
Thursday the president according to
sources refer to Haiti and African
countries by saying quote why do we want
all these people from expletive whole
countries here we should bring in more
people from places like Norway following
a firestorm of criticism from both sides
the president tweeted quote this was not
the language used adding never said
anything derogatory about Haitians other
than Haiti is obviously a very poor and
troubled country suggesting the whole
thing was made up by dams it is not true
he said these hateful things
Illinois's Democratic senator dick
durbin was one of seven members of
Congress who attended the closed oval
office meeting he pushed back at the
president's denial that's when he used
his vial and Bowl
comments calling the nation's they come
from polls the exact word used by the
president not more not just once but
repeatedly Senator Durbin said South
Carolina Republican Lindsey Graham
challenged the President on the spot in
a statement senator Graham said quote
following comments by the president I
said my piece directly to him diversity
has always been our strength not our
weakness but Republican senators Tom
cotton and David Perdue said they do not
recall the president saying these
comments specifically House Speaker Paul
Ryan so first thing that came to my mind
was very unfortunate unhelpful it's it's
obviously disheartening
Utah's Republican congresswoman Mia love
whose parents emigrated from Haiti
invited the President to have a
conversation I doubt that a comment like
that would have been made if somebody
like me is sitting across the table from
you now white nationalists like Richard
Spencer and David Duke have praised the
president's comments going as far as to
tell him to act on it mr. Trump is
expected to return to the White House on
Monday where he will also attend another
MLK jr. event a wreath-laying ceremony
to mark dr. King's 89th birthday
Anthony Errol Barnett with the president
in Florida thanks Errol